i believe it was the david sedaris
episode where you discussed
colonoscopies and i think you you may
have even discussed it on more than one
occasion you actually discuss it too
much i think but it's not the
colonoscopy that i bring up so much as
the drug they give you yeah the problems
you have the colonoscopy the profile
which uh it's the happiest i've ever
been in life
and
it's a high that i'd like to get back to
and so i'm constantly
calling my doctor and saying shouldn't i
have another colonoscopy yeah and the
doctor saying you were here a week ago
and i'm saying i'm just concerned
i think we gotta get back in there
so i was digging through the voicemails
and apparently on google there's also a
text and picture
option and this guy named ray sent this
message in and it just says so that you
guys know i'm on the same crazy
wavelength as you guys i had a
colonoscopy today and had something
written on my butt cheek to surprise the
and the doctor wrote back on it so first
i'm going to show you this and we'll put
this up on the team coco podcast social
media but i've even though this is
visual this is worth sharing i think so
he wrote hi doc be gentle and then the
doctor wrote back in full black marker i
was happy face and he made a happy face
this is not a way for people to
communicate i i don't
i don't think
the uh the good lord gave us uh two
buttock so that we could have uh a
message on one side and a response on
the other i this is that's insane hi doc
gentle and then he wrote i was yeah this
is this man's butt yes this is this
man's bottom okay and um i don't know
i'm not that
confident going into any kind of
procedure where i'm gonna be out where
i'm gonna write a funny message like can
you imagine if i needed some procedure
on my heart and they're like well we're
going to put you under
you have a pretty good chance conan 80
of the time this goes well uh we're
going to crack your chest get in there
and mess around with your
right ventricle
and
then the doctor i get in and they you
know they remove the robe when i'm
passed out and i've got a goofy message
or series of cartoons that i've written
out
you know
oh doctor
here's the key to my heart
he had a gastric bypass but eight
alphabets in a specific order yeah
it's
i don't know where
yeah and yeah you get my point yeah i do
get your point that would be very hard
to eat them in a certain order and then
hope backwards
hope that they lined up
yeah in your gi tract in the correct
order what if it was a really
complicated sentence and you got it all
right except one word was backwards
so it was like hello doctor good luck on
your fishing expedition
instead of expedition and the doctor was
like i'm [ __ ] up
you ate the alphabet in the wrong order
you can't make it out and you're you're
you're swallowing these letters whole
yeah but you have to do them in reverse
you can't chew them you can't do it yeah
i know i think this whole thing is a
dangerous precedent of leaving funny gag
messages essentially easter eggs
for
your surgeon to find
because i want my surgeon focused like a
laser beam on the task at hand and if
the surgeon
is trying to think of a funny response
to my the quip that i wrote right on my
heart
then
what if that distracts the doctor
where's the doctor's like oh man conan
had a pretty funny joke yep stenciled
onto his chest
damn i gotta come up with something
doctor are you okay we should probably
do this quickly he's bleeding out hold
on a second hold on it's a funny
way to come back at conan yeah you think
so buddy no that's not funny doctor his
blood pressure is dropping rapidly hold
on a second
excuse me nurse this is to be funny it's
gotta be
how about
yeah you wish no
wait do i capitalize the you to show i'm
being circus no
you died
conor bryan's gone sir i just figured it
out
i just got it yeah i worry about that
i worry about that i don't want that i
like it oh you like the scenario where i
leave this earth no i like the note i
think that this guy does colonoscopies
probably a lot and he sees a lot of
butts that are just bad have no messages
on it and then he sees this one and he's
like oh somebody actually like thought
about me
yeah and
now he's into it so people don't even
leave a message and he just writes on
everybody's butt after it's over like
another dr anderson colonoscopy
yeah and it's got a signature and a
little logo
yeah uh
i like that i like the idea that maybe
you're right maybe it's nice if we
started writing messages to doctors on
our bodies maybe i'm maybe i'm over
thinking yeah maybe it's nice to just
start writing messages like good luck
doc and remember if you screw it up
there's plenty more o'brien's where this
one came from
good luck doc it's a jungle in there
yeah
yeah
good luck doc you do not where do you
see what i had
i did not fast doc
welcome to the yard sale welcome to the
jungle
i ate a burrito last night
welcome to the jungle you're here for
quite a fright
i'm sorry
playing pranks on a guy who's who's
doing your colonoscopy by not fasting
and then eating all kinds of crazy stuff
i swallowed a parking meter
i don't know why i'm even doing that
voice why is axl rose doing this now
um
well anyway
good luck i mean congratulations on your
fun buttocks prank
you sure showed that colonoscopy giver
the doctor
doctor
said but i want to be more specific that
was not it